an insulated human organ lunch bag and
meat ball shaped gum balls it's episode
nine of loot these Underpants are
printed photo realistically to resemble
jean shorts these USB drives are made
out of actual concrete and these pillows
are in the shape of busts which people
seem to really care about now here's
that woody figure that's incredibly
poseable change his eyes his eyelids
long story short this is what people
have been doing man and for 95 bucks you
could be making these fabulous tableaus
yourself keep things in perspective with
this measuring cup from Fred it contains
facts like this much equals 5,000 drops
of water this much is 20,000 grains of
rice and this much filled with flour
would represent as many grains of flour
as there are people on the planet do you
like watersports but don't have any
friends
we'll grab this remote-control towing
boat for 17 thousand dollars you can buy
this little boat with a tow rope full of
controls it's powerful enough to go 40
miles per hour and create wakes for
jumps and tricks now while you're on the
beach play with your accurate moon beach
ball or if you prefer video games check
out the soon-to-be-released Superboy
this handheld system accepts Super
Nintendo cartridges in the back for
mobile smash gaming for that super chick
in your life get her some Marvel PJ's
she-hulk Captain America and Emma Frost
too hot for you we'll chill with these
neat popsicle molds that make sailboats
rockets and robots if you buy them as
gifts be sure to wrap them in wrapping
paper wrapping paper covered in lyrics
from songs like M&Ms my name is in the
Sugarhill gang's Rapper's Delight
but now nerdy clothes along cat scarf a
Mario level one sweater dresses that
look like Tetris and etch a sketch 3d
glasses and the crawling text from Star
Wars if you already have enough clothes
just grab this knit beanie by Edd's a
user antithetical art Michelangelo would
be proud to see you looking
this for coverage down lower try out
South Park leggings and for your feet
educate yourself with Etsy user yellow
ships infographic poster that teaches
shoe cab you Larry if you're more of a
t-shirt person check out these brainless
tees iPhone you too bowling ball and
bowling pins skeletons and this is a
mugging fork it over
Jenko design has a peaceful bomb base
and here's a light bulb design so that
when you screw in the working end it
looks like this but now free stuff type
in whatever you want and llamas will
spell it out for you or follow these
steps on Instructables to make your own
beautiful bacon roses finally instead of
turning on TV check out Vsauce Leanback
if you haven't yet I want to do one of
these every single Monday and it's a
television length episode of just myself
posting other cool videos I like on the
original channel so the original
creators get the views this week's topic
was outer space in the scale of things
next week I'm thinking optical illusions
we'll see what happens but if you
haven't leaned back yet check it out
subscribe to Vsauce 2 for more and as
always thanks for watching